well
yes
and I agree we look alike for at least six
months and abc up to more than six months
depending on the quality of the hat
more or less they cost between 25 and even
more than 25,2000 dollars
and many know me as the best
craftsman in the world
[  Music]
my name is simón a vélez finale I
dedicate myself to handicrafts, which is
toquilla straw hat weaving
and I have learned since I was 14 years old,
let's say, doing this art for almost 40 years
[Music]
my grandfather and I did know them and  They told me
that their parents I had
when I had a boy who
was just beginning to have
[Music]
when they touch it it seems to be a
silk fabric it feels so soft
I think these hats are the
best considered in the world because the
The quality of the straw is the most important thing
for us. Being this is a man or not. No
chemicals are added to whiten the
straw.
the peace for
the drying the cooking
select the straw to be able to make the
hat to make the armadillo of the
crusader that is called the crab's little brother
and after that you can do what is
the auction the beaten wash the
ironing so that the client already  I
wear it
I am proud to do this
job
every morning when I wake up always
thinking about my job doing
things well keeping
traditions alive is something that is very important to me
but well, may God give me a lot of life
health to be able to continue doing  that
art
[Music]